ursula mertens führt das verfahren gegen
stephan pariert erst ende vergangenen
jahres kurz nach dem attentat von halle
wurde sie an das oberlandesgericht nach
naumburg berufen und starb mit dem
vorsitz des strafschuss senates betraut
ursula mertens ist eine praktikerin sie
hat 20 jahre am landgericht in halle
eine strafkammer geleitet mörder
vergewaltiger räuber das waren ihr
tagesgeschäft ich der bild-reporter habe
sie häufig im gericht erlebt große
mertens ist alles andere als eine kühle
juristin
im gegenteil sie zeigt empathie findet
warme worte für zeugen die mal nicht
weiter wissen und ist auch zu
angeklagten immer nett freundlich und
korrekt heute habe ich ursula mertens
anders erlebt entschlossen entschlossen
von der ersten augenblick an dem
angeklagten keinen raum keine bühne zu
bieten für seine ideologie und auch das
tut sie sehr direkt im zwiegespräch ich
fand es toll wie sie ihm immer wieder
die folgen seiner tat vor augen geführt
hat stephan pariert versucht alles sehr
technisch darzustellen und sie stirbt
ihnen bremst ihn aussagt ihm wie sich
seine opfer fühlen ob es sich daher ein
gedacht hat sie fragt ihn auch wie weiß
ob er weiß was er seinen eltern damit
angetan hat und im magdeburger
landgericht für und jörg völkerling ja
gesagt uns was wird heute am zweiten
prozesstag erwartet in etwa einer stunde
wird es hier im sitzungssaal c24
weitergehen stephan pariert ist vor
exakt einer stunde von der sicherungs
gruppe hier am landgericht magdeburg
abgeliefert wurden am zweiten tag ist
nicht mehr so viel andrang wie gestern
dabei ist ein entscheidender tag denn
heute wird zum ersten mal in der
öffentlichkeit in der öffentlichkeit
dieses
tat video vorgespielt was stephan
pariert mit seiner helmkamera mit dem
samsung smartphone gefilmt hat es wird
für die angehörigen ist wird für die
opfer die hier im saal sind hat sein
selber mit eigenen augen sehen zu müssen
wie ein mensch stirbt wie zwei menschen
sterben
man hat diese bilder haben damals fünf
leute live auf der plattform tritt
verfolgt im nachhinein 2000 leute haben
sich das video angesehen
man sieht ja na l wie sie die straße
entlang kommt und sagt muss das sein
wenn ich hier lang gehe und wie stephan
pariert sie dann ohne gnade wirklich
nieder schießt man hört den halleschen
fc fan kevin es im döner imbiss um sein
leben flehende bitte nein das sind alles
sehen die die zuschauer dann hier auf
den bildschirm im saal auch selber mit
ansehen können und das ist natürlich
etwas vollkommen anderes als ein krimi
sozusagen abends im fernsehen zu sehen
es wird kein leichter tag für die
menschen dann im gerichtssaal aber auch
gestern vor allem für die angehörigen
war es ein schwieriger tag der band hat
sich immer wieder rassistisch und auch
antisemitisch geäußert wie haben sie
darauf reagiert
bewundernswert ruhig eigentlich
ich habe heute mit dem nebenklage anwalt
markus schütz gesprochen er vertritt
neun leute die damals in der synagoge in
halle vor ort waren drei haben den weg
in den saal gefunden um ihm zu zeigen
stefan bald zeigen du hast es nicht
gebrochen
du hast es nicht unser leben genommen
wir sind hier du hast nicht gesiegt
und sie waren wie uns mal clubs gesagt
hat nicht schockiert von dem auftreten
sie haben ihn ja er hat sich selber
entzaubert sagen sie es war diese welt
die sie aus den akten kannten die hat er
hier wieder da geboten aber alle
angehörigen und alle opfer vertreter
haben gesagt dass die richterin
bewundernswerten eingebremst hat indem
sie ihm einfach die konsequenzen seiner
hetzreden vor augen geführt hat indem
sie ihm gedroht hat wir schließen dich
vom verfahren aus wenn du so
weitermachst und das ist die schärfste
waffe die sie eigentlich ziehen kann
denn stefan bald braucht er dieses
verfahren um seine weltsicht sozusagen
darzustellen und vielleicht in seinem in
seiner gedankenwelt das fertig zu
bringen was er damals bei der tat nicht
geschafft hat